now is it possible to build muscle
and lose fat at the same exact time
well let's talk about each point and how they
relate to each other let's start with exercise
exercise is responsible for about 15 of fat loss
and so your diet would contribute to about 85
percent so there is some benefits of exercise for
fat loss the key with building and maintaining
muscle growth is this right here intensity of
exercise as well as the volume of exercise because
if you're doing keto and you're losing weight and
you drop out your exercise you're not going to
continue to build muscle in fact it might shrink
a couple other points to consider recovery of the
exercise if you over train and don't recover
let's say you're working out every single day
and also adding on to that you're not
sleeping because you're stressed out
then the benefit of this is not going to be there
so you really need all these factors in place
the cool thing about exercise is it can stimulate
growth hormone up to 700 that's huge and growth
hormone helps you build muscle now let's switch to
the carbs the lower the carb the more the weight
loss right but carbs stimulate insulin which is
an anabolic hormone it makes things grow so now
we have a problem if we go with too many carbs
over 50 grams it's going to stop the weight loss
but what if we did this what if we consumed a
little more protein what if we kept our carbs
lower definitely below 50 grams and we increased
our protein a little bit more than 8 ounces per
meal what that's going to do it's going to
increase insulin and glucagon now i will say
that too much protein can potentially slow down
your weight loss so it's a bit of a balancing act
between having the right amount of protein and
the right amount of carbs so maybe you're going
to play around between 30 to 50 grams of carbs
and keep your protein between 8 ounces and then
maybe try to increase it a little bit to actually
provide a little bit more insulin to the muscles
but at the same time increasing glucagon which
actually helps you burn more fat and so this point
right here the carb amount and protein amount is
an individual thing you have to play around with
this to get the sweet spot but i just want you
to understand the relationship between these two
fat provides energy for doing more exercise if
you go low fat and you're doing fasting you could
potentially make your body a bit too tired and not
have the energy to do the exercise so we need a
certain amount of fat we don't want to go below
75 grams and that will force your body to burn
more of its own fat and not turn the dietary fat
as much into ketones but having sufficient amounts
of dietary fat in your diet will definitely
help the next factor right here which is
fasting fasting is the most powerful thing to lose
weight because it dramatically brings your insulin
way down and if you're doing consistent
fasting you can handle a little more protein
because you're going to give your body a chance
and the time to digest a larger amount of protein
now as far as fasting and your muscles go when
you fast you could potentially stimulate growth
hormone up to 2 000 percent now let's compare this
to exercise which is 700 percent you get a major
spike in growth hormone when you do fasting
and growth hormone is all about building
muscle and when you fast there's also a protein
sparing effect that occurs and that means simply
that your body is not going to be using your own
muscle protein as fuel it protects the muscles
of course there's going to be a point where you
burn off all your fat and then the body is going
to starve and use its muscles but it's not going
to happen when you do routine fasting or even
periodic prolonged fasting one point about fasting
it's very important to consume enough sea salt
about one to one and a half teaspoons a day with
potassium and magnesium to get your electrolytes
if you don't do this your energy is going to
go down it's called keto fatigue and you will
not be able to exercise because your muscles are
not going to have the electrolytes they're going
to get tired in all of your cells you have what's
called a sodium potassium pump that generates the
electrical energy to allow the muscles and nerve
to work so as you can see now the importance of
how these different factors relate to each
other to build muscle while you lose the fat
hey before you go real quick i have
a course entitled how to bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today